60 years ago earth was detect we won the
war they destroyed half the planet
everyone's been evacuated with a mop-up
crew this is Mission Control are you an
effective team we are an effective team
I'll buy you two around the drinks when
you get up here two more weeks Chuck and
we can finally leave and join the others
don't take any chances jack is one of
the last humans left on earth after a
massive war that has left earth
basically uninhabitable doesn't seem
right we won the war no we have to leave
he's a futuristic blue-collar guy
basically he fix his drones he's
fascinated with the relics of the past
the Yankees cap which he finds when he
finds the structures of Old Earth
there's a connection to it that he can't
quite explain every day he goes down to
earth to do this job while trying to not
get killed by the enemy
it's very dangerous when never Jack's on
the surface because he's always
vulnerable to an ambush pick up coming
in Jack and vika our partners she's his
communication Officer systems are green
no plant began leather boys am now you
know you're right gotta work on that
they've been stationed here together
just the two of them for the past five
years one day a spacecraft impacts near
Jack's location drones are mobile I'll
keep your tag out of bed they are human
Jack come on once you just stand down
the drums will handle this that's a
negative tower it's for the firing of
survivors jack is trying to figure out
what is happening here this is
immiscible into behavior and in the
wreckage he finds this woman Chuck how
do you know my name I've been watching
you jack it's time to learn the truth
you need to know what happened
everything that he knows becomes
inverted the people you work for lied to
you jack knows he has to fight literally
the world is at stake in this war you
don't have to die
have to die
it's time to come home I'm not gonna do
that it's epic it's just an epic story
how I mankind to survive this is the
only way